nothing replaces a human connection
and nothing is going to get you farther
along than to be able
to connect with people
[Music]
this class is not only going to be about
being a tv journalist though we're going
to get into that
that's not what this is about it's about
negotiating public speaking
body language shoulders back head up eye
contact
i cannot think of any line of work that
you are not
going to benefit by communicating
effectively
and authentically you can't fake it you
can't fake the funk baby
it's about sharing with people how they
can be a better communicator
tell you a secret listen
genuinely take interest in somebody look
somebody in the eye
when's the last time that someone has
done that
this is something my mama used to say
make your mess your message
everybody's got something cancer divorce
unemployment
fill in the blank that's not the tragedy
it's if you don't take the time to
understand
why was that placed on my path what am i
supposed to learn
i remember when i went on national tv
with diane sawyer by my side she's
holding my hand and i announce
that i have breast cancer when you allow
yourself to be vulnerable you're showing
a strength
not a weakness and people see that and
people will thank you for that
yeah there are times when i'm still
frightened but why would you let
fear keep you from your destiny you're
looking at that next lofty goal and
you're like oh how am i going to get
there
the secret to getting ahead is getting
started
so let's get started i'm robin roberts
and this
is my master class
[Music]
you